des arts plastiques du chances du
théâtre et que des filles
le collège privé pour jeunes filles de
la chêneraie a déménagé du chéné à
voisins le bretonneux
depuis la rentrée 2010 est une vingtaine
d'élèves en uniforme sont inscrits de la
6e à la 3e ont fait quand même lui
matière de l'éducation nationale mais on
a en plus deux heures de théâtre par
semaine et quatre heures de chant et
on travaille comme ça on apprend des
chants un peu toutes les sortes
et on travaille aussi sur des dessins de
la par exemple on a fait des affiches
pour la journée portes ouvertes et on en
fait pour pour différentes occasions ou
alors pour des projets enfin les cours
l'établissement est centré sur l'art
mais aussi la religion avec des
causeries mensuelles thématiques pour
assurer une formation chrétienne
les parents adhèrent à ce programme et
sont ravis de la non mixité c'est un âge
où les filles sont quand même mûr plus
doués et je pense que pour les garçons
c'est très mauvais d'être avec des
filles et je pense que pour les filles
elles développent bien plus leurs
qualités féminines en étant dans un
environnement surtout à cet âge là à
l'âge de l'adolescence de la puberté
c'est un âge qui est pas facile et voilà
donc pour moi le collège c'est très
important qu'il soit pas dans une classe
mixte un projet éducatif bien différent
des autres établissements pour des frais
d'inscription de 350 euros par mois
[Musique]